[Music]
the kaibab plateau is home to one of the
last ponderosa pine forests in the
southwest
it's a unique habitat protected by grand
canyon national park
and a spectacle to behold
[Music]
less than five percent of the six
million annual visitors to the park make
it beyond the rim
[Music]
for most
a trip to a scenic overlook is enough to
get a taste of the beauty in this magic
place
[Music]
but for those with a sense of adventure
traveling into the heart of the park can
be quite the thrill
a grand canyon rafting trip is the
adventure of a lifetime
it can take two weeks to raft its entire
length
entrusting their fate to the river
paddlers navigate their way
through at least 80 big water rapids
including the infamous
lava falls
the waters of the colorado are a
rafter's mecca
but it's best
not to fall in
the grand canyon pink rattlesnake
only found in this region
it's perfectly adapted to canyon life
[Music]
while the river is a barrier to some
for him
it's an opportunity
[Applause]
swimming gives him the freedom to search
for new hunting grounds
his ability to scour more of the park
gives grand canyon its own natural form
of rodent control
spring is a common season to spot
rattlesnakes
[Music]
you